did woke policies cost kids thousands of
dollars in scholarships Virginia is now
the epicenter of this damaging Equity
Crusade at least 13 schools there are
being accused of withholding merit
awards from Top students after the
college application cycle it was
reportedly done to avoid hurt feelings
but the parents say the move cheated
their kids out of thousands of dollars
worth of scholarships Governor Younkin
is outraged saying quote they have a
maniacal focus on equal outcomes for all
students at all costs and his attorney
general is vowing to investigate one of
their directives to the school district
was equal outcomes no matter what even
if it means treating some students quote
purposefully unequally one mom said you
know my daughter has done everything
right since the first grade she has
studied so hard and now she's realizing
she may not go to her school of her
dream simply because of who she is
because she's korean-american that goes
against everything we believe in this
country and that's why we have this
investigation
you know Dana you talked about the drip
drip drip yeah this one too this was a
drip drip yep we heard about one school
that it was that school and then we kept
hearing about more schools and more
schools it sounds like this was an
organized effort to keep that
information away from kids where they
could benefit yeah so the first parents
that found out about it they only they
actually happened to just see the letter
from the National Merit Scholars
Association on their child's desk at
home randomly and they're like What's
this oh we just got okay so that's when
the parent calls and they say oh this
was a unique circumstance very it's an
aberration this is not anything that was
happening anywhere else but the attorney
general that you just saw Jason mayares
he ran his uh campaign when he was
running for her office on rooting out
this woke nonsense that priorities
prioritizes equity and racial
segregation over Merit so he said I'm
going to look into this well it's only
been about 10 days and now we know that
13 schools were doing this and I want to
know know if it's just in Virginia or is
this a nationwide thing and is it like a
secret bat signal that goes out to the
schools like don't put it in writing but
let's all make sure that we don't upset
anybody by making sure that they don't
feel bad if they don't get a National
Merit Scholarship but this is a civil
rights issue and that's what he is going
for on this one the other thing is
there's this group called parents
defending education and they developed
this massive database to figure out
where the schools using public taxpayer
dollars to hire woke Consultants where
it was going and they found about 20
million dollars in contracts Nationwide
and a huge amount of it was spent in
Virginia so he's doing what he
campaigned on and we'll see what how it
turns out you know Brian the schools
initially said you know this was done to
it's because of human error and it was a
unique situation and now we've got the
Attorney General uh he's going to sue
for unlawful discriminations violation
of Civil Rights Act you know better but
I would think if you're an individual
they're supposed to get a scholarship
and you got this marital award you're
applying it's not on your resume you
should probably these individual
families should be able to sue also the
fact is Young can slam the district for
hiring a 450 000 a year Equity coach and
this started to me with the
valedictorians remember when they just
decided we're not going to have a
valedictorial We're Not Gonna because
you don't want to we don't want to make
everyone else feel bad for not being as
smart and working as hard I thought
that's this craziest thing ever well
that was nothing compared to this but we
got to start and the Asian Americans
again they're the ones who sued to get
rid of affirmative action and they're
getting screwed here because they
outwork everybody else you know they
want the the outcome to be the same for
everyone but what's wrong with allowing
a kid who's got a dream who can run
faster who wants to work harder to
achieve that dream absolutely but don't
let them slide out of the uh the eye of
scrutiny here this is unfair it is
creepy it may even be criminal what they
did in intentionally denying
notification of winning a merit uh
scholarship so you couldn't put it on
your resume so you don't get into the
college of your choice tens of thousands
of many many Asian American Kids
affected by this this is rotten and I
think that I I believe this is worse
than the uh the Scandal where people
were paying to be on the fake rowing
team and all that I think that this will
be a bigger story this is it should be
this is awful what they've done to these
children you know in most of the kids
who are affected by this were Asian
American kids and it's interesting that
they then stopped admitting them in the
numbers that they had previously I'm
pretty sure this happened to me right
you did you have a full ride to UCLA
basketball uh you know I didn't die
because of the merit scholarship didn't
come through no you're stuck here and I
had to go to my second School Berkeley
I'm sorry to hear that where did you go
kill me no I didn't go I didn't think so
you know what what activists really want
right now they want everybody the Casual
Observer to replace the word equality
with Equity begins with EQ you very
simple that's why you start Hearing in
the speeches less about equality and
more about equity and then when you ask
somebody like what does equity mean
they'll try they'll kind of use the
terminology for equality but it's not
the same right so it's really important
that people understand what the
difference is because one is about peace
and the other is about war you know
equality is simply defined as people
have the same opportunities to achieve
the same goals we're all at the same
starting Place Equity though Equity is
we enforce limits on achievement so no
one achieves more than anyone else that
will punish the really hard workers that
leads to war that is socialism so Equity
uh equality gives everybody a step up
that Equity crushes from above and you
have to remember we have to remind
yourself of this whenever you run into
this situation because people are going
to always try to replace equality with
equity and you want you can see it like
in New in news reports they will just
they'll just let the word Equity fly by
that is an evil word it is a word
right now it's a word that caused that
is part of socialism it is socialism
yeah it is Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now